You can attempt to flee, you can try your
best to hide, you might even valiantly try
to fight back, but when the bloody dawn of
the Scarlet King finally stretches across
the multiverse’s collective horizon, there
will be almost nothing that we can do.
Every sadistic monster, every world-ending
horror, every dimension-transcending malicious
reality warper, none of them even begin to
approach the danger and pure, undiluted evil
of the Crimson Khan himself.
We’ve covered this horrific eldritch entity
in several videos before - from his SCP-001
proposal, to the potential SCP identities
of his hellish spawn, to the earthly vectors
for those children: The horrifying SCP-231.
But today, we’re not interested in once
again going over how the SCP Foundation feels
about their greatest enemy.
That’s only one side of the story.
Today, we’re going to explore the origins
of the Scarlet King through the cold, dark
eyes of a very different source: His very
first earthly worshippers.
It all began with the Daevites.
We’ve discussed this extinct culture before
on this channel in passing, but to fully understand
how we know the cursed information we’re
imparting today, we first need to understand
exactly who the Daevites are, and why they
were such a terrifying society.
We’re not talking about a mere Group of
Interest here like the Serpent’s Hand or
the Chaos Insurgency, we’re talking about
an imperialistic, militarist civilization
that brought pain, terror, and suffering to
everyone and everything they encountered.
The Daevite culture was arranged into a series
of dense, urban city-states that supported
themselves through brutal slave labor, farmed
from their own people and weaker groups that
they conquered through extremely hostile takeovers.
The name “Daevites” is derived from the
culture’s ruling class, the Daevas, powerful
and potentially immortal sorcerers who maintained
their abilities through ritualistic torture,
sacrifice, and cannibalism.
Much of what we know about these monsters
is derived from a cursed book titled “A
Chronicle of the Daevas”, designated by
the SCP Foundation as SCP-140, an incomplete
chronicle.
Much like its subjects, the book is bloodthirsty.
Ink or human blood spilled around the book
will be stolen and incorporated into text
on its sordid pages.
That would be ominous enough, but it gets
much worse: As editions of the book are “revised”
through these sanguine updates, the book literally
revises the history of the real world, moving
the extinction date of the Daevites just that
much closer.
The book is one of the Foundation’s most
closely guarded anomalies because if enough
revisions are made that the Daevite culture
enters recent history, or even worse, the
present day, it would mean the end of the
world as we know it.
In all likelihood, the lucky ones among us
would be killed or written out of history
immediately.
The rest would become slaves to the Daevas,
or become victims to their occult bloodlust.
After finding out all this about these horrifying
people, it really shouldn’t come as a surprise
to you that they’re some of the first recorded
worshippers of the Scarlet King in our dimension.
You’d have trouble finding a more perfect
representation of the King’s philosophy
around pain, cruelty, subjugation, and a world
ruled by primitive violence.
That brings us to what we can learn about
the King himself from artifacts left behind
by his first and most ardent followers.
A collection of tablets that act as a kind
of sacred, holy creation myth for the Scarlet
King and his gruesome pantheon was discovered
at a Foundation-sponsored Daevite dig site,
and using other Daevite sources, these tablets
were translated into a harrowing account known
only as Dust and Blood...
Between the darkness below and the darkness
above, at the beginning of all things, the
Tree of Life was planted.
This was the moment when all things across
the multiverse were given form.
Life and death began.
Expansion and entropy.
Order and chaos.
And out of all that, a caste of Elder Gods
was also born in the vast and quivering dark.
Many of their names have been lost to the
pages of history, but one that was not was
a being known only as Khahrahk.
Khahrahk was born into humble beginnings.
He and his forgotten siblings roiled in the
abyss, the only thing separating him from
everything else being the very awareness that
he was stuck down in the abyss.
He was both blessed and cursed with self-awareness
in a void filled with ignorant darkness.
He felt the sting of loneliness, pain, and
resentment.
And if existence was such pain, what was the
point of existing at all?
In fact, what was the point of anyone or anything
existing, if they were all just doomed to
this dull suffering?
At this moment, Khahrahk found his calling:
Bringing about the end of everything.
But first, he needed strength.
To achieve this, he devoured his brothers
and sisters in the abyss, stealing their strength
and their essence.
This is known as the First Sin of Khahrahk,
and he was punished accordingly with even
greater pain as he grew.
And of course, this did nothing but strengthen
his resolve.
Blinded by pain, fury, and pure hatred, he
vowed to uproot and destroy the very tree
of life itself for putting him through this
awfulness.
This was Khahrahk’s first bloody conquest.
He clawed his way up to his throne, slaying
and devouring countless other Elder Gods over
eons of brutality and war.
Some were allowed to live for showing loyalty
to Khahrahk, and they would amass great power
under him, but it would only ever be under
him.
He was beginning to form what would later
become his legion of terrifying, supernatural
warriors and servants.
When his conquest of the Lower Realms of Creation
was complete, he gave himself the title of
King of the Darkness Below.
He also took the name Khnith-hgor, to reflect
his new position.
His Kingdom of absolute cruelty and despair
would claim the souls of anyone unlucky enough
to stray too close, and put them through the
suffering that Khnith-hgor had so resented.
But his work wasn’t done.
He was just getting started.
The King of the Darkness Below declared all-out
war on the rest of creation, opening the floodgates
and releasing his terrifying forces on the
surrounding kingdoms.
Their operations were the template for the
Daevite way of warfare and life: They would
conquer and destroy, and force the survivors
into servitude.
Anyone who dared defy the orders of the King
would be broken and destroyed.
His word was law, and the law was absolute.
At some point during the expansion of his
empire, Khnith-hgor enslaved a wise and beautiful
goddess known as Sanna, or the Mother of Those
Beneath Us.
She detested the King and his seemingly limitless
barbarism, but she was smart enough to follow
his orders and feign loyalty to ensure her
continued survival in the short term.
This, however, would not ensure her safety
forever.
Khnith-hgor had no intention of ruling and
conquering alone; he wished to create an evil
dynasty to rule underneath him, and carry
out his every command across the multiverse.
He decided that Sanna would be his first bride,
and forebearer to the first generation of
his spawn.
She was made to lay with him for seven days
and seven nights, so that she could give birth
to seven children - seven being a highly significant
number in the world of sorcery, and particularly
in the world of Khnith-hgor.
Once Sanna had served this purpose, Khnith-hgor,
who could not feel anything even close to
love, had no more use for her, and crushed
her to death.
When he rose up from the grisly deed, his
armor was covered in Sanna’s blood.
This striking image inspired his final name:
Shormaush Urdal, the Scarlet King.
From Sanna, the Scarlet King gained seven
daughters, who in an act of further monstrosity,
he also made his seven brides.
Each gave birth to a legion of nightmares,
which would become the Scarlet King’s most
loyal and dangerous soldiers.
The Scarlet King also gave each of these brides
a sacred seal, so that they would never die.
The first bride was A’tivik, who was the
favorite of the Scarlet King despite having
the smallest brood.
She and her children were granted great wisdom
that would guide them to victory in battle.
Her seal was vaduk, “dominion.”
The second bride was A’ghor, born with a
great hole in her soul that left her forever
in want.
However, she gave birth to a huge legion,
who then begot even greater armies to go forth
and conquer in the name of their terrible
grandfather.
Her seal was kifenn, “longing.”
The third bride was A’distat, a creature
of unparalleled malice and hatred that extended
to even her own sisters.
She and her brood were unmatched in their
ability to spread desolation, destruction,
and pestilence on the battlefield.
Her seal was hezhum, “desolation.”
The fourth bride was A’zieb, a great berserker
if ever there was one.
She took the form of a huge beast, as did
all her children.
They would rampage through enemy forces, killing
scores of soldiers yet seeming impervious
to all damage dealt against them.
Her seal was ba, “wrath.”
The fifth bride was A’nuht, a beast with
a frail body but an incredible mind.
Her children all proved to be adept sorcerers,
with the ability to craft and rework reality
however they pleased.
This would prove to be a great asset to the
Scarlet King, but he also feared that their
powers would allow them to rebel against him,
and so, he had them all crippled.
Her seal was ner, “lack.”
The sixth bride was A’tellif, the most silent
and secretive of all the Scarlet Siblings.
Her children had the remarkable ability to
change their faces, and walk unnoticed among
their enemies.
They also had the ability to open the Ways
between worlds, allowing the Scarlet King’s
endless war to spread across dimensions.
Her seal was usheq, “hidden.”
And the seventh and final bride was A’habbat,
who was physically the weakest of them all,
but the only one with the strength of spirit
to disagree with and rebel against her father’s
diabolical wishes.
Her children were brave warriors and hunters,
many of which are aligned with her mission
to stop the dreaded Scarlet King.
Though thus far, none have yet achieved this
lofty mission.
Her seal was xokib, “hope.”
As the Scarlet King’s power grew, more of
the multiverse fell into his poisonous clutches,
rotting the very roots of the Tree of Life.
As the seven brides and their legions spread
out, they recruited more cosmic power players
for their grand war effort.
The Hanged King pledged his allegiance, the
Prince of Many Faces swore his loyalty to
the Scarlet King, the demonic forces of The
Factory worked in the name of the unholy monarch,
and the horned demon lord Moloch bowed his
mighty head.
The Daevites firmly believed that the victory
of their almighty Scarlet King was as certain
as the sunset.
No matter what opposes him - be it the Serpent,
the Broken God, the arrogant fools like the
SCP Foundation - he and his forces will fight
on.
They will tear the Tree of Life asunder, carving
away at everything until nothing remains.
Existence will be at its end, and the last
sound the multiverse ever hears will be the
Scarlet King himself sighing in relief after
a job well done.
He’ll finally be at peace.
Unless, of course, somebody stops him.
If the best minds the Foundation has to offer,
with all of its resources and knowledge and
connections, are able to create some kind
of weapon or shield against him.
If SCP-999 truly is the child of A’habbat,
prophesied to bring about the end of the Scarlet
King’s terrible conquest.
If there’s some unknown solution, waiting
out there in the dark, we may finally be able
to stop this rampaging Elder God from destroying
all we hold dear.
But those are all very big Ifs...
Now go check out “SCP-001 - The Scarlet
King” and “Children of SCP-001 The Scarlet
King - Is SCP-999 Really His Son?” for more
on the endless disturbing mystery of the Scarlet
King.